Thank you for taking a break from Starfield
to watch this video.
Indiana Jones and the Dial of Destiny begins
in a flashback at the end of WW2 where Indy
is hunting down an artifact that the nazis
have and he’s also been captured.
From here, the movie starts pretty quickly
in terms of thrusting us into a ridiculous
scene in which Indiana Jones miraculously
survives being hanged, while also having a
bomb go off in the tower that causes him to
fling all over the place.
So before going into all of that craziness,
why are the Nazis even bothering about going
through all this trouble in killing Indiana
Jones.
They’re literally staring at him with guns,
but they decide to go all the way up to the
top of this tower and then set up a rope to
hang their prisoner.
Why not just take him out back and execute
him with bullets?
Especially given that the entire compound
is evacuating with some haste.
But this is obviously done so that Indiana
has some chance to escape.
And the means in which he escapes is just
so baffling that the movie is already off
to a rough start.
Surely this won’t be the only extreme convenience
that happens.
After getting out of the tower Indiana Jones
steals a car and knocks out the driver with
his iconic one punch KO.
This is a movie stereotype, but I’ll accept
it.
The more annoying aspect to me is that Indy
is literally doing this in the middle of a
courtyard in full view of dozens of people.
Then some officers get into the car and don’t
even question the fact about why there’s
a passed out soldier right next to the driver
seat.
Or there even being a motorcycle right behind
the car he’s hijacking that definitely would
have saw someone get tossed out of the vehicle.
So were 2 for 2 already and it only gets worse
from here.
Indy eventually goes off course to chase after
the Train in which the artifact he’s after
is on.
So he has to take out some bikers and ends
up hijacking one of them as they dive into
the forest.
Now to say that Indy is extremely lucky in
this scene would be an understatement because
they somehow don’t hit a single tree despite
not looking at where they’re going.
He literally has the luck of Domino from Deadpool
2 in this movie so far.
Not to mention that he’s actively fighting
someone over control of the bike.
So (by sheer dumb luck - Harry Potter 1) Indiana
Jones gets onto the train.
And does all the devoid of logic nonsense
finally stop here?
Of course it doesn’t.
Indy saves his friend Baz and while they’re
running away from the Nazis down the train,
some planes bomb the anti-air gun.
Now everything up until this point was pretty
lucky, but to me this takes the cake as being
the luckiest.
So the anti-air gun doesn’t actually get
fully destroyed and perfectly spins around
right to the exact angle to where it shoots
at the Nazis pursuing Indy.
And the train just so happens to be going
through a turn so that the AA gun is firing
at the enemy and not the heroes.
This so conveniently ends up essentially wiping
out all of the Nazis chasing them and if the
writers writing this moment think this was
good by any means then they’re delusional.
We want to see our heroes overcome major conflict
without the will of god solving it for them.
So since most of the Nazis on the train are
dead now, it allows the more prominent villain
to have a fight with Indy.
However, what immediately doesn’t make any
sense is why the villain doesn’t have a
gun that he simply shoots Indy with.
He literally had one 5 minutes prior while
questioning Baz and for some reason he opts
to use the artifact as a weapon.
What a nice guy giving his opponent a better
advantage.
But wait, he actually does have his gun and
he doesn’t use it and Indiana Jones steals
it while they are wrestling.
It gets knocked away and now Baz has the gun.
Instead of chasing after the gun, the villain
simply allows himself to be shot by Baz with
virtually no protest.
You’d think someone pointing a gun at you
would be more of an imminent threat than a
guy with a whip, but whatever.
Then Dr. Voller, whose the main villain scientist,
feels left out so he also decides to join
them on the roof since he’s after the Antikythera.
Which up until this point is a mystery as
to what it does.
At least he isn’t dumb enough to not initiate
their confrontation with a gun.
Indy hands it over to him and then while on
the side of the train, Dr. Voller gets bonked
on the head by a metal pipe.
Now what do you think happens from this point?
Does Voller A: flat out die on the spot from
pure blunt force trauma, B: does he become
a vegetable from his brain being so destroyed,
or C: does he simply get a small scar on his
forehead with no clear mental impairments.
Hey you picked the depressingly obvious answer
that is C. The writers basically make Dr.
Voller an impenetrable superhero for being
able to survive this.
The train was moving at probably about 40ish
miles per hour and he got struck in the head
by a metal pipe.
If I were to just fall down on the ground
and slam my head onto the concrete I’d probably
have to go to the hospital, let alone getting
slammed in the head by a pipe at high speeds.
The man should have been decapitated at that
force and speed.
If anyone has seen Hereditary then you know
what’s up.
So yeah, the prologue for this movie feels
like I’m watching the adventures of Tintin
instead of an Indiana Jones movie from how
crazy and absurd all the action setpieces
have been so far.
Going to present day, Baz’s daughter Helena
finds and confronts Indy and they talk about
the Antikythera.
It turns out that she’s a not an actual
good person and is someone who sells prized
artifacts on the black market.
Which is what she intends to do with the Antikythera.
It also turns out that Voller is alive and
is pursuing Helena, along with US government
agents cooperating with him.
Given that he helped the US land on the moon.
Voller also has his own goons who are much
more loyal to him, but are also very sloppy.
Because while in pursuit of Indy and Helena,
they murder two upstanding civilians in cold
blood.
Which right away is pretty insane that the
government agents wouldn’t have immediately
cut all ties and have arrested them on the
spot.
I’m pretty sure some random chick selling
stolen goods isn’t as important as killing
two civilians, but I don’t know what the
writers are smoking.
So a chase initiates and Helena screws over
Indy by leaving him behind by locking a gate.
This seems unnecessarily cruel given that
he’s her godfather and she’s essentially
handing him over to the wolves.
Like he’s on her side and I don’t know
why she needed to betray him here.
I’ll go more into this subject later on
in how it impacts her character arc, and her
relationship with Indy throughout the movie.
But because of this, Indy gets captured and
has to escape the bad guys.
Which I’m not entirely sure why they even
need him since Voller already knows where
the auction for the Dial is going to be held.
They’re literally just kidnapping this teacher
for no apparent reason, other than he briefly
interacted with Helena.
For all they know she just stole that relic
from him given that she visually betrayed
him.
But yeah, he ends up getting away by physically
besting his opponents.
Now let that sink in for a second.
Harrison Ford is 80 years old and he has enough
strength to overcome these muscular brutes
in their prime?
Along with him being able to run away from
them.
Like they should easily be able to catch up
but I guess they can’t?
So Indy hijacks a horse from a cop that disappears
and a chase initiates.
Indy ends up conveniently escaping in the
subways in which he luckily doesn’t get
decimated by the trains and has perfect timing
when it comes to getting into one.
Still not sure why the bad guys want him so
badly, but heyyyy, we wouldn’t have an action
scene so don’t question that.
I feel like this would inherently be a better
action scene if it was done via Helena escaping
these bad guys.
Given that she’s much younger and would
be more believable.
Instead, they make it to where she quickly
gets away.
Moving on, Indiana Jones is now wanted for
murder since the police somehow came to the
conclusion that Indy was probably the one
to kill his colleagues.
I guess he really didn’t like that retirement
gift.
So now Indy is a wanted man and they are publicly
showing his face on the news.
So since he’s in a pinch, he calls his friend
Sallah to taxi him to the airport.
I’m not really sure why that was necessary
and why he didn’t just call a normal cab.
This character’s return because of this
doesn’t really have much of a point and
feels more like a lazy attempt to garner nostalgia
from the audience.
If you’d think it’s because Indy’s popular
now from his face being all over the news
and needs to be more incognito, then that
would make sense, but that’s immediately
contradicted by going through an airport without
being recognized.
I know back in the day airport security was
light, but surely there are probably some
police present, especially since there’s
a murderer on the loose.
I feel like that would be an absolute given
to upgrade security in the area.
But nope.
Indiana Jones simply just gets on his plane
and goes to Morroco in which the auction for
the Antikythera is being held.
Also while on the plane, there’s this whole
flashback of Indiana Jones taking the Antikythera
from Baz and has a brief encounter with Helena.
However, this exact moment was discussed between
Indy and Helena so it feels completely unnecessary
to include this.
This also especially feels worse given that
the movie is almost three hours long so having
to sit through what should have been a deleted
scene is rough.
Moving onto the next action setpiece, Indy
shows up to the auction unannounced and crashes
the party.
A fight for the dial inevitably ensues and
at some point, the dial flies into Indy’s
hands.
When it does there’s this brief moment in
which Indy punches a bad guy and he goes flying.
Which I find hilarious that these GUNS are
packing that much power.
Now this particular shot of Indy with his
whip facing an onslaught of guns is inherently
really silly.
I remember this being one of the main shots
in the trailer, but I was always like how
the hell would Indiana realistically get out
of that situation.
And realistically he can’t because the bad
guys just comedically shoot at nothing while
he ducks under the table and they don’t
bother shooting under it.
After this, Teddy steals the dial and then
runs right into Voller who steals it in return.
How convenient.
Voller then takes the dial into a car with
his goons and they drive off.
Indy and Helena would pursue them, but they
are stopped by a mob boss that Helena married
for bail money and obviously used.
He’s very upset with her and is essentially
threatening her, and yet, Indy comes in like
a child complaining to his teacher that Helena
stole his candy.
Like why would he care?
You are barging into this conversation and
are disrupting a mob boss.
In any real-world scenario, the mob boss would
simply kill the person disrespecting him like
that, but this comes across as such a childish
script.
So eventually Helena upsets the mob guy and
they are now being chased by them.
During this whole chase scene, I find it really
admirable that Harrison Ford is running around
given his age, but at no point do I ever buy
the fact that he’s able to outrun anyone
or should be able to keep up with Helena.
He’s basically hobbling around.
They eventually steal a vehicle and get chased
around a bit and then through divine intervention
from the script writer gods, they randomly
run into Dr. Voller.
Now this may not seem like that big of a deal
from watching this video, however, so much
time has passed since he drove off that there
is no possible way they were able to catch
up to him, or let alone find him.
So this is obviously a crazy coincidence and
is a contrived way for the heroes to fight
the bad guys.
Not only does this happen once, it actually
happens twice because they go off on another
side tangent of getting chased by the mobsters.
This entire scene is just so nauseating in
terms of where all these characters are in
relation to each other and it’s as if they
are teleporting around wherever the writers
need them to be without following any logic.
Also during this whole chase let me show you
this moment.
Pause.
Now do you think the vehicle they are in tumbles
down this stairwell and they all die, or do
they conveniently survive without any injuries?
The fact that you instinctively picked the
second option is very worrying for the writing
and how they present this ridiculous action.
It’s also pretty crazy that they are able
to come to full stop after rocketing down
this stairwell and don’t explode into the
wall at the bottom.
What’s even more ridiculous is that the
vehicle is fine and is still able to drive
after this.
But yeah, from here it’s just a circus of
devoid of logic antics that again makes this
movie feel like Adventures of Tintin and any
grounded and realistic action from the first
few movies are nonexistent.
So the bad guys get away and overthrow their
US associates.
Apparently, the final blow for the US agents
was getting arrested in a foreign country
and not killing US civilians.
Also, this quote doesn’t seem to make sense.
(US agent says 3 civilians were killed) If
I remember correctly they only killed two
people, but maybe they killed another in a
deleted scene or something.
Going over to Indiana and Helena they have
some riveting discussions like this.
It’s kind of annoying that the writers are
making their interactions this juvenile and
so far we are basically half way through the
movie and they are insufferable.
They finally decide to work together after
Indy practically begs to tag along and they
meet up with Antonio Banderas.
Pretty convenient that he knows a diver in
the exact area they need to dive in, but whatever,
between everything that’s happened that’s
the one thing I’ll buy.
While on the boat, Indy eventually tells Helena
that his son who was played by Shia LaBeouf
died in the military.
At the very least the writers acknowledge
that the character existed, but it still stings
that they nonchalantly kill his character
offscreen.
Also this scene in terms of dialogue lacks
subtlety since Indy lays out everything to
a character he isn’t even getting along
with.
The characters dive down and get the next
piece of the puzzle that they are chasing
after, and Voller shows up and hijacks the
ship.
They arrive while they are diving which is
insane timing given that they were only going
to be down there for 3 minutes.
So that’s a contrived way to give control
over to the villains since our heroes weren’t
present.
They also cut one of the lines to oxygen for
one of the divers and luckily it wasn’t
an important character.
I also don’t understand why this random
NPC didn’t just activate his life vest and
simply rise to the surface after losing air.
Instead, he chokes to death and falls into
the abyss and dies within seconds.
Surely he would have been able to hold his
breath a little longer since these are divers,
but heyyyy, don’t think about that.
Get it!??
Because of time travel.
So Voller steals the graphikos tablet which
will point them to the final piece of the
Antikythera and asks Indy to decipher it.
Indy in this moment makes the decision to
not give in and by doing so I guess he’s
alright with having all of his friends be
murdered.
Because of this, Antonio Banderas is deleted
out of the movie and it just feels so odd
to have him be in the movie if he’s only
going to be given like 5 lines.
In response to this, Indy makes a cute attempt
to try and tackle this hulk of a human and
obviously fails.
What were you expecting you’re 80 years
old man!
Since Indy doesn’t want to decipher the
tablet and we’ve run out of background characters
to kill, Helena steps up to the plate and
asks for compensation.
Not sure why she waited for someone to be
killed and at this point I assume she’s
a flat out sociopath.
Also, Voller has complete authority in this
situation and is threatening them, so him
agreeing to hand over 100 grand to Helena
is pretty surprising.
All he has to do is threaten to kill her kid
companion and she’ll immediately cave.
While deciphering the tablet she shows Indy
that she has a stick of dynamite that was
glaringly set up earlier, even though it didn’t
show her grab any.
The shot directly after this in which she
turns around and is greeted to the hulk looming
over her is pretty funny though.
This guy is literally staring down at her
and didn’t even notice her pull something
out of her pocket to show Indy.
Surely he had line of sight, but I guess he’s
just zoned out.
Even after this, the blocking of this scene
assumes that you forget these two goons in
the corner are even there.
Because Helena is lighting the stick of dynamite
within full view of them.
Even when she does light it, they aren’t
even active within the scene and don’t immediately
capture Indy and Helena.
They’re just standing in the corner as if
the director put them in time out.
So since they evaporated from the scene, the
director created a contrived sense of believability
for them to escape.
I also love how Indy when getting into the
boat doesn’t even bother to take cover when
getting shot at.
His plot armor is so thick that bullets don’t
scare him anymore.
From here, Indy sets the wooden boat on fire
like a mad lad and reveals a golden dial underneath
the tablet.
The fact that he then picks it up immediately
is pretty insane given how hot it should be.
Now we're in Sicily since this is where the
next half of the Antikythera is located.
While here, Teddy has an integral scene of
eating ice cream and by complete and utter
fate he stumbles across the bad guys chilling
on the docks.
I find it funny how one of the goons menacingly
walks out of the shadows like Batman as if
he’s been waiting for Teddy to fall into
his trap.
This scene gives off the same energy as Euron
Greyjoy swimming ashore right when Jaime was
passing through.
Then since Teddy has gone missing, Indy picks
a random place to check on his whereabouts
and heyyyy, he just so happens to witness
Teddy get kidnapped.
It’s only as if this is a big city and Teddy
could literally be anywhere.
Yet another contrivance to give Indy the confirmation
that Teddy has been kidnapped.
So now Indy and Helena need to steal a car
which like the opening is extremely easy since
the awareness of these background actors is
nonexistent.
Indy simply walks up to the car, opens it,
and drives off; and by the time he starts
the engine, that’s when these people notice.
Not when you know, they slam the door shut.
Out of all the ways to steal a vehicle I don’t
know why it needs to be this devoid of logic.
While on the way there Indy says this “They’re
not gonna hurt him.
They’re gonna use him.”
How would you even know!?
They’re goddamn Nazis and have proven in
the past to be extremely ruthless and they’ve
already killed a bunch of people.
But they draw the line at kids?
Arriving at the tomb of Archimedes, Indy and
Helena somehow get there before Voller despite
them being behind.
By this point, since there have been so many
dumb aspects bombarding the viewer, they are
probably so numb to it that they didn’t
even question this moment.
From here, this is really the only solid portion
of the movie I didn’t hate since it includes
some fun tomb raiding.
Although it still has some hard to believe
aspects in the script like this area barely
being explored despite it being a popular
location, this light revealing the way to
go while the sun clearly isn’t visible anymore,
Teddy escaping the bad guys by forcing him
and his captor into the river that has a convenient
kid sized hole for him to escape, and Indy
being able to rock climb given his stellar
physical condition.
I do give the movie some bonus points for
this funny rant that Indy goes on though.
Inevitably, the bad guys catch up to Indy
and Helena and Teddy also found his way into
the tomb even though he was swept away in
a river.
I’m kind of just quickly touching on these
really dumb aspects when in reality these
are major deals.
They’re becoming so numerous to the point
that I’m becoming desensitized to the stupidity
in this movie.
So Teddy is up on this big slab of rock and
Helena spots him.
While the bad guys behind her who have a better
view of the whole room somehow don’t.
Also like the boat scene, these background
bad guys won’t do anything when the action
pops off because if they were actually active
they’d easily be able to kill the good guys
since they’re right behind them.
So after some brief action, Indy tells Helena
and Teddy to get out of there and Indy is
now captured.
For whatever baffling reason, the nazis don’t
quickly pursue after Helena and Teddy and
capture them as well.
But if that were the case, the movie would
instantly end.
Also, Indy’s plot armor is starting to get
unbearably thick since Voller suddenly wants
to keep Indy alive.
I don’t why this is the case since they
have no relationship or dynamic given how
fast their past encounters have been.
They’ve basically have had barely any back
and forth dialogue throughout the movie and
the writers expect us to buy the fact that
Voller wants to keep him around to witness
his victory?
Like why would he even care?
So now through yet another contrivance, Indy
gets a front row seat to watch the climax
of the movie.
Helena and Teddy catch up to the Nazis as
they are boarding their plane and Helena manages
to narrowly climb through the landing gear
before it takes off.
For Teddy, he hijacks a plane that’s conveniently
ready to take off and is able to get the plane
into the sky.
This may seem wild, but at the bare minimum,
the movie set up an infatuation he has with
planes so this is funnily one of the least
dumb aspects so far.
However, the main question is going to be
how this kid will land the plane successfully.
Will he A: Somehow land the plane like a pro,
B: crash the plane and walk away with no injuries,
or C: there’s a pilot randomly sleeping
behind him who lands the plane for him.
And the answer is C!
What a miracle that this pilot is here or
the story physically won’t be able to operate.
I feel like that’s what this movie has been
so far.
It’s the writers connecting all of these
idiotic aspects with duck tape and hoping
it functions in any way.
Moving on to the fun bit, we have the actual
time travel portion of the movie.
Now even after watching the movie twice I
still don’t understand how this dial is
able to get someone to a precise place and
time in the past.
But yeah, between everything in the movie,
I’ll just buy that time travel exists and
instead of going back to Germany, they are
teleported to the Siege of Syracuse in 214
BC.
This is where the movie finally gains a small
ounce of fun as everyone freaks out about
being sent to the past.
The most hilarious moment during this scene
was when one of the Nazis opens fire on the
Romans.
When this happened I bursted out laughing
in the theater from how ludicrously ridiculous
it was.
I just don’t know what he was trying to
achieve here, that’s not going to do anything.
So eventually when flying around they slowly
get brought down by numerous scorpion bolts
and don’t pay any attention to the fact
that the plane Teddy is on hasn’t been hit.
It may be smaller, but given that they are
getting spammed by scorpion shots, it’s
pretty lucky that they’re unscathed.
Just before the plane crashes, Indy and Helena
jump out with the only parachute and share
it together as they float down to the ground.
They’re greeted by Archimedes who brings
them back the Antikythera that he conveniently
found from the crash site.
So out of all the devoid of logic aspects,
the movie surprisingly makes sense from a
time travel perspective and doesn’t make
a glaring paradox.
Although partially but whatever.
During this scene, Indy wants to stay behind
since he’s still shot and is slowly dying.
Pretty irresponsible of him honestly in terms
of how he’ll change the future, but this
is actually a pretty emotional scene and Harrison
Ford did an excellent job here.
He delivers a lot of sincerity and you can
really feel the amount of care and love he
has for the character.
It does feel a bit weird in the moment since
you are like “are they actually going to
kill another beloved character like Han Solo”
but luckily they don’t commit to that and
Helena knocks his ass out.
On one hand I like this reversal in having
Indy get one punched KO’d, but on the other
hand, the man is 80 years old and this would
probably be a death sentence for the guy given
that getting a concussion at that age probably
isn’t the best.
So since he gets knocked out we hard cut back
to Indy’s apartment and everything is resolved.
That feels a little cheap, but since the movie
is already creeping up on the mid 2 hour mark
I’ll take that as the director doing us
a solid.
Now taking a look at Helena’s character,
I personally think that her arc here in that
she cares deeply about Indy and desperately
wants to save his life is unearned.
Especially from an emotional standpoint because
she’s left him to die on multiple occasions
and they only had a few brief scenes of bonding.
So her drastically changing and suddenly not
caring about money anymore doesn’t feel
like it was properly built to.
I like this arc in theory, but the writers
butchered her character by making her so cold
and heartless for half the movie.
So yeah, now Indy teleported back to his apartment
and we get a happily ever after with his wife
returning.
Just forget about the fact that he’s still
a wanted man for allegedly murdering his colleagues.
And that’s Indiana Jones and the Dial of
Destiny.
It’s pretty sad that this movie ended up
having such a dumb and juvenile script and
I was wishing for something that was still
fun while not disregarding logic in every
second of the film.
Since the first few Indiana Jones movies were
grounded in logic.
Besides Crystall of Skull, that movie also
deserves to be stored away and be forgotten
about.
Thank you for watching and let me know in
the comments what you thought about The Dial
of Destiny.
And follow me on Letterboxd for more reviews
on movies.